the stage has said events of the biggest
venues coming back to las vegas this
upcoming fourth of july weekend
and that is the focus of this week's
issue of las vegas weekly magazine we've
got editor at large brock recki joining
us now from las vegas weekly
hi brock nice to see you can't wait to
have you in person
one of these days soon but let's get
started with the first major concert at
allegiant stadium
who is it and how many people are we
expecting
that's what a lot of people are saying
who is this guy not everybody knows
his name's elenium his real name is nick
miller but he's kind of a rising star
dj and electronic music producer
he's been playing vegas clubs and big
events like the electric daisy carnival
for years
and this is going to be probably the
biggest show of his career at allegiant
stadium first concert at allegiant
uh they're expecting 35 000 uh
an audience of 35 000 for this show 35
000. okay and pronounce his name one
more time for me
elenium millennium millennium yes no m
very cool all right all right that's a
legion
maybe too cool for the likes of me but
very cool indeed
[Laughter]
now perk theater this is more my speed
they're going to debut one of the first
major headlining residencies with none
other than bruno mars
that's right and bruno is one of those
uh shows who
you know booked these comeback shows and
the demand was so great
that he added many other shows so he's
basically playing throughout the month
of july
at park theater we're going to see other
residencies from
carlos santana and gwen stefani and of
course
celine dion and everybody at resorts
world coming back online later this year
but
bruno is the first one back on this trip
oh that's fantastic
i saw share there it's just a great
intimate setting i still got to see
bruno mars so i better get
get on that ticket yeah everybody in the
newsroom here is saying yes you got to
get on it
all right so resorts world had a huge
festive opening but there's even more
planned for this weekend
hard to believe yeah we were just
talking about the grand opening party it
sounds like this weekend is going to be
just as big
if not bigger it's the actual opening of
their
pool club which is called iu day club
and that's from the zook group and on
the 4th of july sunday night miley cyrus
is going to be performing a concert at
this day club and the cool part is
she's going to be broadcasting this show
on that huge screen on the hotel tower
so people out on the strip are going to
be able to see the concert
and that's incredible and that means
that people across the valley will also
be able to see it too
because it's that magnified oh my gosh
so you don't even have to
you don't even have to buy a ticket to
just be out oh we know what's going to
happen right
las vegas boulevard is going to be
packed
it's gonna be packed anyways for fourth
of july well thank you so much brock we
greatly appreciate your time of course
grab an edition of las vegas weekly
this week take a look at the cover page
right there the stage
is set we're gonna toss things over to
ted
and kier you know like here at a new zao
we've got that former helicopter pad
that looks directly at that screen right
so
it's going to be fantastic